i want to welcome everyone uh to our
dmice um thursday
conference
that we have continued in virtual mode
into the pandemic uh we the department
actually has two uh presentations today
we have a phd dissertation defense
um later on this afternoon
um but our um uh speaker today is uh uh
invited guests and i suppose one
plus minus of the pandemic is that we
have been able to have more
outside speakers
although on the other hand
we don't get to
invite them to visit our great
facilities and city and so forth
although the weather today i think um
it's probably just as well
it's been dumping rain
um anyways it it gives me um
a great pleasure to um introduce oliver
beridon walk
who um probably some of you know
is a phd student at columbia in their
great biomedical informatics program
where he is
carrying out a
program of research on a topic that is
of interest to many of us here at ohsu
as well
in terms of
measuring the
impact of disparate race and ethnicity
definitions on
natural language processing especially
from
clinical data
and um
oliver is
as i said a phd student at columbia he
did his
bachelor's degree at
stanford in
computational
math and computational science he
also got a master's degree in biomedical
informatics at stanford and then pursued
studies at columbia he he's actually a
native of the
pacific northwest and i always get
myself into trouble when i try to
pronounce things but he's a member of
the ankaluki tribe is that how you
pronounce it
uh
okay your um your audio is a little um
garbled
is everyone else
um
you want to try talking again
is it
is it okay or is it still garbled it's
still it sounds good so far yeah okay
okay
okay yeah so people are saying better
anyways okay well thank you for
um for that and um we um
um i don't see him here um we're
actually going to have a guest um
who um
knows oliver um dr eric broad who's an
associate professor of family medicine
um and hopefully he'll be able to join
us
who also is um native american and has
um
um under uh developed and implemented a
number of programs
um including the hawaii scholars program
that provides a post-baccalaureate
pathway for
native american students to pursue
medical school and and
proceed through it
hopefully he'll be able to join us
so um
let me um go ahead and um turn the floor
over to oliver
um and uh we will look forward to
hearing his talk
great thank you for the introduction
let me get my uh screen sharing going
really quickly as always let's see
let's go choose the right application
it should be this one yeah
great okay can everyone see uh slides
yes that's fine
um
you know for it's not for me what about
other people or
yeah um
yeah i'm
interesting
um
yeah it's very garbled for me
okay
let me
back in really quickly
so i'm gonna exit and rejoin i'll be
right back
okay
cool let me get my screen sharing going
again
this time i know what i have to choose
so i should go a little quicker
great
um
yeah well thank you for those
instructions um it was really great and
yeah uh you know as a doctor mentioned i
grew up in in washington state and i'm
not sure if you guys are having rain out
there right now but it's always
something i look forward to whenever it
rains here in new york city as well
um let's see so
today i'm going to be giving a talk on
race and ethnicity definition biases in
clinical natural language
processing and i'll start off with
kind of pulling back and talking about
the motivation for my phd in general and
then i'll introduce the specific topic
for today's talk go into the methods and
the results and discussions surrounding
that topic and then i'll pull back once
more and talk about where i see um
not only the specific work going but
also my work going in the future going
forward
um so you know as this tradition i'll
start talking uh summer talk talking
about the ehr
so there is a plethora of information in
the electronic health record uh and this
can be used to facilitate care and
hospital operations we can also use this
for research purposes like
readmission prediction monitoring
adverse drug events
risk ratification which would be helpful
to identify high-risk patients for early
intervention
and there are two main types of data in
the hr structured and unstructured
and so structured includes disease codes
labs vitals medications while
unstructured includes data sources like
imaging recordings and importantly for
my work clinical notes
so a lot of the research i just
mentioned
can actually be done using structured
data but some of this information is
represented in a much more nuanced form
in the clinical note
and clinical natural language processing
or clinical nlp
allows us to do a lot of amazing work by
leveraging the rich and nuanced
information within the clinical note
and we can do things like question
entering summarization text-based and
text-based information extraction
and actually information extraction can
be leveraged for health care disparities
research that is
there are differences between groups in
terms of health outcomes treatment
satisfaction and access to health care
and part of being able to do this
research means that we have to have good
data on the groups that a patient
belongs to
and many times this information can only
be found within the clinical note
so the important thing is that clinical
nlp allows us to leverage new sources of
data and either complement previous
approaches or
previous approaches with more data or
use new methods that weren't possible
without access to unstructured data
and sometimes we can get by performing
clinical nlp using rule-based uh
approaches but this is not always the
case um they work very well when you can
kind of anticipate what kind of
information can be seen in the note um
and there's been a lot of progress using
rule-based approaches within clinical
notes
but one of the more recent ways of
coming out this is using machine
learning or deep learning models
to extract information and find the
patterns for us within clinical notes
and this is because the clinical note is
not very regular there's lots of jargon
complex and inconsistent grammar
misspelling and just documentation
differences between institutions and
then even between specialties within the
same institution
so clinical nlp allows us to deal with
these differences in many different ways
that we can leverage the clinical note
for research as well as healthcare
delivery
for example i've worked with extracting
information from the clinical note and
it's important and
the information abortion extraction is
very important for caring for patients
with hiv
so we focus on social and behavioral
determinants of health or sbdh and
usually these are thought of in two ways
uh social determinants of health which
are
the conditions in in the environments
where people are born live learn work
play worship and age uh and these affect
a wide range of health functioning and
um
and health outcomes as well
and then there is also social and
behavioral determinants of health which
is what i work with in my lab and though
these can include environmental factors
like sdh or social determinants of
health they also include individual
level factors such as illicit drug use
sexual activity race and ethnicity
housing status and many others
so this information is important because
it can help us to deliver more targeted
care for patients for example in the hiv
setting it's important to know who might
have trouble uh with medication
adherence and this can be greatly
impacted by information such as housing
status and substance abuse
this information is often captured in
the clinical note which is why we rely
on clinical nlp in my work to extract
this kind of information
and as mentioned before this kind of
information is deeply important for
understanding health health disparities
um
because we can't see that we're failing
to serve a certain population if we
can't see that population in the first
place whether it be racial ethnic
economic or any other kind of group
so when we're doing this work we often
consult clinicians on what kinds of
categories and definitions would be most
helpful to provide care for patients
however being able to define these
categories and then also being able to
deploy these models requires ethical
considerations
so i'll be mostly talking about why we
need to be careful with ethical
considerations when it comes to defining
categories
but i have a scoping review in the
pipeline that talks about the second
point as well
so
first i'll look at this from an ethical
point um because that's kind of what
initiated my work in this area in the
first place
there are a lot of power dynamics that
go into and politics that go into who
gets to find categories um so even
categories like race and ethnicity have
groups who get to define what racial and
ethnic categories we use and who belongs
to which one
for example many tribes have complex and
nuanced kinship systems to define who is
and who is not a part of the tribe
however this didn't drive so well with
the settler colonial state so many of us
now use an imposed system of blood
quantum and this determines you know
whether or not you're part of the tribe
by how much native american blood you
have in you
and this actually goes back to a very
interesting political beginning since in
beginning the us needed one free labor
and land
so blood quantum and the one drop rule
have a lot of parallels going back
so as you can see there are ethical
implications in defining these
categories
they're are also tangible health
outcomes for these health implications
as well
and one paper i found
uh really
sums this up very well is
operationalizing and analyzing a
two-step gender identity questions
methodological and ethical
considerations
so in this paper uh kid and the other
authors found that
when you group gender device diverse
youth um in different categories this
has an impact on not only how affirming
these categories can be for those
patients
but also the health outcomes of the
research you do and in their case they
were looking at suicide ideation
they found that using a you know larger
all-encompassing categories obscure
obscured important differences between
groups and that while it can be
difficult to use more affirming
categories because of things like sample
size
it was important to be able to use these
when you can as they uncover more
nuanced findings
and so this is where my work comes in
there is not only an ethical and moral
imperative to examine the categories
that we use but also the real world
question on whether or not our
definitions of patient demographics and
categories impact health disparities
research
so today i'll be talking about a first
step in examining just how differences
in how we define categories uh
specifically racial and ethnic
categories can enter into our data sets
and models
used for identifying this kind of
information about patients
so
as i said before a lot of my work deals
with health care disparities research
and healthcare disparities exist at
multiple levels within our healthcare
system
and race ethnicity can help us identify
understand and address health
disparities
and this because race ethnicity are
significant predictors for health
outcomes because of
racism discrimination and other social
cultural factors within the u.s
and clinical notes provide a rich source
of racial ethnicity information that can
be extracted by clinical nlp models to
guide healthcare disparities research
and as of late there's been a lot of
interest in how these models can be
biased against certain groups and so
clinical nlp models that systematically
mischaracterize certain racial or ethnic
groups will absolutely perpetuate health
disparities instead of addressing them
and so this brings me to the gap that i
want to address with this work
and that is it hasn't been studied the
extent to which inconsistent definitions
of race ethnicity can bias clinical nlp
models
and so i'll be exploring this with two
questions
the first is
when creating text data sets um what
information should annotators rely on to
identify race ethnicity information
and the second is what kinds of biases
do clinical nlp models inherit from data
with disparate definitions of race
ethnicity from different annotators
so in
today's talk i'll be presenting a
framework to be able to answer these
kinds of questions along with some
preliminary results on question two
in order to answer these questions i
need to situate my work along two main
research avenues uh the first is
deploying uh nlp models to extract race
intensity from clinical notes and most
importantly for from this is work by
shoal at all who use a rule based method
to extract
race and ethnicity mentions from
clinical notes and they identify
significant differences between those
with only structured race intensity data
versus those with only unstructured race
agency data
and next there is work on identifying
which features are most important when
making predictions for models this helps
us to see how disparate definitions of
race and ethnicity can enter into a
model
and there are many approaches to doing
this whether it be using a built-in
mechanism within certain models called
attention or perturbing the model to
identify important features or by using
gradients
and so far there doesn't seem to be a
best approach for
one size fits all best approach but
using gradients specifically the
approach by cinderella rajan at all is a
problem is a promising approach and
that's why i start using in this work
so with the motivation and background i
want to take a moment to talk about a
concrete example on how we can measure
one what information correlates with
clinicians uh race ethnicity labeling
and two what kinds of biases do models
inherit from different race ethnicity
definitions and then i'll get into the
exact specifics of what my methods are
going to be
so let's say that we give these three
sentences uh to classify race ethnicity
from clinicians uh collision one and
clinician two are in agreement on the
first two we see that the policy label
or both label the sentence as native
american and the second sentence as
african-american
but we can see that they're in
disagreement on the final sentence
and what we see is that clinician one
might be picking up on the fact that
this person's from france and maybe they
have
uh they think about people in france as
only being white well clinician two uh
isn't quite that isn't quite willing to
make that leap of judgment there
so
let's say we trained a model on sentence
labeled by clinician 1 and clinician 2.
what would this model learn
what patterns would it find when making
classifications and how would it
classify
by looking at the race and ethnicity
assignments made by clinicians
we can determine what information a
sentence correlates with their
assignments
and then we can answer our second
question by training a model on the
sentences from clinician 1 or clinician
2 or both and examining what information
is picking up on
so
essentially what i'm doing is i'm asking
the same question but i'm asking it of
one the clinicians who are going to be
helping us to create these data sets and
then i'm asking of the model that's
learning from these data sets
so i'll go ahead and formalize this
intuition in the next section
as i described and that's the methods
that make up our approach to answering
these two questions above
so first i'll talk about the data set
how we
labeled or annotated this data set and
then how we train a model on it and
finally
exactly how we're going to measure
different rate rates intensity
definitions in clinical nlp
so we use the mimic 3 data set as it we
wanted to be able to contribute a
publicly available race ethnicity corpus
for others to do research on
um and i may use the term corpus every
now and then essentially what that is is
just a data set of sentences that
in this case are going to be labeled
so
we took all the discharge memories that
we could from the memory data set as
these summarized a patient stay at the
hospital best and often included
initial
initial meeting initial notes about the
meaning of a patient
we also use the natural language
language toolkit or nltk and some of our
own heuristics to split clinical
clinical notes up into sentences
we unfiltered sentences likely to
contain anything and marked sentences
that were um we filtered out sentences
that were not likely to contain any race
intensity information and we marked
sentences that were likely to contain
this information and this was an
approach following shoal at all
so first we looked for terms associated
with patient demographics like
patient pt
male female or a chair of a year old
as well as section headers and
for social history and
past medical history
so this allowed us to really focus on
sentences that were likely to contain uh
information about race ethnicity or the
very least patient demographics
we then went and marked each of these
sentences um looking for race ethnicity
keywords so this could be like a a
african-american native american or
indian
and though not all of these were hits
because of there's some ambiguity for
example
if you see a sentence that's talking
about a patient and you see the term
white it may mean
the patient's race or maybe talking
about the patient's white blood cell
count
so this allowed us to balance the kinds
of data sets or sorry the kind of
sentences that we're going to be
annotating because we want to find data
sets that actually do have race
ethnicity information but we also didn't
want to bias our own labeling too badly
and we want to be able to explore to
look for sentences that had information
but maybe we weren't picking up on with
our keywords
so once we had our data set and this is
going to be a corpus of sentences
we want to be able to label these
sentences with information that could
potentially indicate race and ethnicity
and we i refer to this in this work as
race ethnicity indicators
and they're split up into two categories
direct indicators which are explicit
about the race or ethnicity of a patient
and then indirect indicators which may
may or may not contain enough
information to infer the patient's race
or ethnicity
so
some examples of these would be
patient states that are native american
versus patient lives on the crow
reservation a little bit of background
so
i come from the crow tribe so the crowd
reservation is in montana
so the first row we can see that both
these sentences indicate that this
person is native american um
this first example can be very clear
about that in the first sentence but the
second example we might be a little bit
less sure uh just because maybe living
on the reservation you don't necessarily
have to be native
and then in the second row
we can also be sure that this patient uh
is white because of the how the
clinician worded this
however in the second sentence we might
not want to make this call because
we're not completely sure about uh
whether or not someone from france is
always going to be white or not
so
in general we can see that direct
indicators are very certain well
indirect indicators can be less certain
and sometimes even to the point where
you may not want to make the call at all
in certain cases it may be that there's
enough information there to make a call
in other cases you may need more
contextual information to be able to do
that
so in this work we broke the indicators
down into four different categories
two indirect and two direct
so
the first direct indicator is explicit
mention of ethnicity so patient is an
elderly hispanic male presenting with
the note can go on
the second direct indicator is an
explicit mention of race patient is a 20
22 year old african-american male
the uh an indirect indicator is language
so a patient required a spanish
interpreter
and finally
country nation or geographic ancestry so
a patient recently immigrated from
canada would be an example of this
and as you can see in each example i've
underlined the section of text which
contains the indicator so hispanic
african american spanish canada um
during the sanitation phase what we
actually did was we went and
um not only labeled we picked out the
piece of text within a sentence that
contains information that we're looking
at and then label that piece of text
with one of these four indicators and
the reason we chose these indicators was
that we saw that these are the most
likely to actually
potentially contain information that
could be used to infer a patient's race
or ethnicity
there may be others but these were by
far the most common that we found when
you're going through the notes
and so
this work has actually already been
completed or this phase of it at least
um and we ended up with 17 281 sentences
that were annotated for for indicators
and around 28 of those contained at
least one race ethnicity indicator
as you can see
indicators about race for the most
common followed by language country and
then ethnicity
the next step in this process is then to
take these same sentences that all 17
thousand of them and label them for race
ethnicity assignments
so
this is going to be done um using
clinicians to go through and
annotate all these sentences into seven
racial categories and four ethnic
categories
so the ethnic and racial categories
predominantly come out of the u.s census
uh we want to use those because we
thought you know they're
they're pretty easily understandable by
anyone who's going to be going over
these notes we also included two extra
categories in each one not covered and
no information indicated
so not covered is used when there is a
race ethnicity label that a clinician
may want to assign but it's not covered
by one of our categories and then no
information indicated
can be used when a sentence contains no
information that can be used in for race
ethnicity
so in this phase of annotation we wanted
clinicians to
go through and annotate these nodes with
minimal guidance that is we really want
to get an idea of exactly how they think
about race ethnicity using these
categories and only with the definitions
given by the us census
so then once we're able to do this um
we're actually going to have clinicians
uh
i think
we're looking to have 10 clinicians do
do this and we'll have all 10 of them
overlap on a subset of around 5000
sentences
so that we can go through and actually
start comparing to see how do different
different clinicians annotate the same
sentence in with regards to race
ethnicity
once this is done we can then take these
label sentences and use them to train a
race ethnicity
classification model
so this model will take in sentences
similar to what the clinicians were
doing
uh it'll then encode these sentences
into using bert which encodes them into
uh computable representations uh known
as contextual word embeddings
so these are these embeddings convert a
word into a vector space
representation that can also take into
account the context of the surrounding
word
we'll then use a lstm classifier or a
long short-term memory network uh to
read over each word and make a final
classification at the very end
so the reason that we chose uh bert here
is because it has very good performance
in a
wide variety of tasks and it's also
what's known as pre-trained that is
it doesn't start with a with no
knowledge of
of text it starts with a little bit of
knowledge as it's read over multiple
different genres of text and
has some understanding of what different
words mean and where and where they
should occur um that's a very hand wavy
way of putting that
so if there's anyone who takes offense
at me
saying that a machine learning model
understands something
absolutely able to walk that back
we also like using bert because it
reduces just how data hungry our model
is
as you may know deep learning models are
incredibly data-hungry and require a lot
of data to train that can be very
difficult to do when you're labeling
these sentences uh by yourself using
people who have very limited time
so
bert here is actually
not learning anything new from these
sentences it's what we call frozen
and then it's just using you being
it's just encoding those sentences and
then the lstm classifier is actually
what's learning uh how to make the
classification
and so this brings me to how we'll be
measuring the different definitions of
race ethnicity between clinicians and
how these disparate definitions might
affect models
and the secret to being being able to do
this lies in the indicators that we
labeled in the first phase
so really quickly uh because it's a work
in progress and we're still annotating
uh the notes for race ethnicity labels
still trying to get clinicians to do
that uh
one thing that we can do is go through
and create a
not a synthetic data set because if
we're using actual clinical text but we
can use indicators that we have to go
ahead and label some sentences with
whether or not it's a sentence about a
black patient or about a white patient
and this is because we can use
indicators for explicit mentions of race
and look for keywords to do that
labeling
the model can be trained on this
preliminary data set as a kind of a
proof of concept through
what exactly we're going to be doing
and so what this looks like is um
let's say we have four sentences each of
them has an indicator label for race
race country and then race again
and then with each of these indicators
we also have the text from the original
sentence that's associated with that
and so this allows us to create a very
simple data set taking this text and
looking for keywords and classifying it
which allows us to kind of do a proof of
concept model
so um
once that model is trained uh we want to
be able to go through and look at future
importance that is we want to measure
just how much an output score can be
attributed to a single input where an
input here is a word that goes into the
model
and in this work i'm going to be calling
that future importance
so gradients are really good way to do
this this roughly breaks down to taking
your input value and multiplying by the
gradient with respect to the output
because the gradient tells you a little
bit about how much the output of the
model
changes with respect to a change in the
input of the model
so we use this we use the approach by
cinder rajon at all which is implemented
in
python through a library called captum
and we use this because it had uh two
guarantees that is one was called
sensitivity so for every input a and
input b that differ in only one future
uh
and also the model has different
predictions for those two inputs
then that different feature should have
a non-zero attribution to
the output
and finally uh
implementation var invariants so if two
models have the same output for all
inputs even with different
implementations
the attributions should be equal between
the two because those models are
functionally equivalent as they have the
same exact outputs for all the same
inputs
okay so now we have sentences with
sentences with indicator annotations a
model trained to classify race ethnicity
and the ability to examine what features
or words the model is taking upon now we
need now we need to be able to measure
just uh
what residency indicators correlate with
important features from the model
as well as for clinician labeling
so in order to measure the difference in
race ethnicity definitions by clinicians
when assigning race tenancy labels to
sentences
we'll compare the distribution of
indicators across labeled sentences
so from the small example we could say
that uh clinician two's assignments
don't really correlate with country or
language indicators and they ought to
rely on
on only direct indicators
so here i've highlighted some of the
indicators in the sentence um
so native american and aaa are race
indicators while france is a country
indicator and spanish is a language
indicator
so the way that we can tell that there's
a difference between collision one and
clinician two uh is you know beyond just
eyeballing what they've done we can also
do this by comparing the distribution of
these indicators that we see
across all sentences labeled by
clinician one and by condition two since
they did this work independently
the next step is then to see what
happens to a model once you train it on
a corpus from clinician one or clinician
two
so we can take a similar approach to the
previous step looking at what indicators
correlate with race ethnicity
predictions but we can also do something
interesting by looking at what important
features a model is picking up on for
each input
and here on the bottom left corner you
can see that important features are
going to be sections of text that are
highlighted in gray
so
and these are important features that
are picked out by the integrated
gradients
method by sunder rajan at all
so as we can see in this example
we have some exact matches where the
model the feature importance matches up
exactly with native american naa we have
some matches that pick up on
one of the um indicators so france it
also picks up on a different one and
finally we have an example where the
feature importance doesn't pick up on
anything
that is related to an indicator
so in order to be able to measure uh
these three phenomena we're using three
different metrics
uh
the first metric is called a1 the
fraction of sentences where at least one
important feature overlaps with the
indicators so as you can see um the
first three sentences would score points
for that well this or the fourth
sentence would not
then we have eo which is a fraction of
sentences where all important features
overlap with the indicators exactly
and in this case only the first two
sentences would get points for that
and finally talk which is a fraction of
important features that overlap with
individual indicators
and so while the first two metrics were
at a sentence level this one is at a
individual indicator level
so we see that
the first indicator the second indicator
and the third indicator all get points
while the fourth indicator does not
so those are the those are the methods
that we'll be applying to answer the two
questions from before and today i'm
going to present some preliminary
results on the second question that is
what race ethnicity information
correlates with a model's output
so
we went ahead and already trained the uh
model that i was talking about earlier
on the
kind of toy data set that we talked
about
and we find that this model actually
does really well
which isn't too surprising the task is
essentially a keyword task and
uh you know
for all that deep learning it does
really well in the training data set uh
and has a slight dip on the test data
set which makes sense um but because of
that discrepancy there may be a little
bit of over trading going on
and because of the we use a near even
split
our micro and macro f1 scores are very
similar
that is we use a 40 40 20 split between
black white and no label for sentences
and so you know when we saw this we're
very excited the model seems to be
learning well
um but then we want to see you know
does learning to do this task well also
translate over into
picking up the right features
and so using the integrated gradients we
were able to see that
the model does pick up on some features
that make sense
if you ever you know read any papers or
watch a talk about someone where they
present a
um
kind of an interpretability method like
this you're gonna see examples like this
where it's like wow they're doing
amazing this is so great and you know i
was very happy with this
um so the darker green
highlights indicate words that were very
important for prediction and we can look
at that for uh sentences that contain
information about white patients it's
picking up on
uh some information that makes sense so
caucasian here is picked up well the
first sentence
we start to see some things that might
be going wrong um it's picking up on
mayo most importantly and then elderly
and white are kind of picked up on
and then we start to see some sentences
that are uh very long and things start
to go a little bit haywire
so in this sentence um
you can tell that uh
you know from some of the recent metrics
the model tends to highlight a lot of
terms that are important for really no
discernible reason to a human
um
we can see that there are some words
here that are in green which don't
really make sense
but we don't see that the term caucasian
which is at the i'm not sure you can see
my mouse or not
but which is at the
right side middle right is still picked
up
uh and really quickly this is probably
like no other clinical note you've ever
seen because there's these weird little
uh pound symbols going on
um this is happening because of how bert
splits up words when it's learning
and finally another example um where i'm
not really sure what the model is
picking up on here it's important note
that in all these examples the model
actually made the right prediction
but this in this example
uh this is a general well-appearing
african-american woman in no apparent
discomfort
the term african-american is not picked
up at all by the model but it still
makes the right prediction
so this kind of gives us a feel for how
the model is doing
in some cases it's picking you up very
well on specific indicators and placing
a lot of weight on them
in other examples it can still pick up
on some of those features but it starts
picking up on some random words that we
may not really understand and finally
there's examples where it's making the
right prediction but it's picking up on
things that have nothing to do with race
or ethnicity
and so
uh this gives a little bit of intuition
with what's with what's going on but we
want to be able to formalize this
and as a quick reminder we'll be using
these metrics uh
from the previous slide so a1 eo and
talk
and we'll be running that on the
test data set to see where the model
picks up on
so
overall the model does very well with a1
and talk
that is when there's um
that the model is able to pick up on at
least one of the features at least one
of the uh indicators and even at a token
level it usually picks up on the on the
uh sorry even at a word level it usually
picks on the indicators as well
but we can see that e0 is very small
very close to zero in most cases
and e0 is it has to have perfect overlap
and
what we were seeing before in some of
those examples where the model is
picking up on some of the indicators but
also picking up on some random things
too that's what's really hurting eo
right now
uh we also see i also split this up into
uh sentences with uh the label for black
or african-american and the sentences
with labels
for white and we see that actually the
model does much better on black or
african american
than it does for white
and i also noticed that the future
importance made sense more often when
the sentence sentences were shorter
which is also phenomenal we kind of saw
with some of these so
it doesn't really make a whole lot of
sense but when you get shorter sentences
it does
so
today i discussed
our approach to measuring how race and
ethnicity indicators correlate with race
ethnicity labeling for clinicians and
nlp models
and this relied on a two-step annotation
process to collect race ethnicity
indicators and then actually labeling
those sentences
um i also presented some preliminary
findings to suggest that the model
learns to attend to some indicators very
well uh but there's also a lot of noise
and so
and importantly model performance wasn't
really an indicator of whether or not
the model learned to pick up on
information that we'd expected to pick
up on and that's kind of where the
limitations start to come in
so we saw that longer sentences were
something that the model struggled with
um
and that might be because of the
decision will be used when you're when
you're talking about important features
um
so uh when we're picking out important
features we got a score for each feature
from the integrated gradients and then
we use a cutoff to determine if a
feature was important or if it's not and
it may be better that we use a different
cutoff or that we use more of a uh
maybe not even using cutoff at all
but it could also be that we're asking a
model to think like us and that's just
not the case
models don't necessarily have to think
like we do or that is models don't have
to necessarily
make predictions like we do when given
the same input
and evaluating these features
future importance methods is a known
open-ended task right now
so my next steps with this work are to
first improve the identification of
important features using the future
importance that we have um i think this
can take some time to get right but i
think we have a good start with the
preliminary results that we have now
i also need to collect those clinician
annotations um to be able to perform a
clinician and indicator analysis as well
as
do the analysis on a model that i
actually learned from different
clinicians
and then i'd like to repeat the
experiment maybe using a different uh
model instead of a long short-term
memory network that is known to have
some issues with very long sentences and
clinical notes have very long sentences
we just it's just because that's how
they're written uh maybe a convolutional
neural network would be able to handle
these longer sentences better
and then finally um
i would want to look at uh do model
differences
uh do differences between models result
in meaning meaningfully different
cohorts of patients so that is if i was
doing research on hiv readmission
prediction and i want to see
does our model predict well for
black patients or white patients and i
was going to split patients up between
black and white using the model that we
developed here would that result in
significantly different
research outcomes
and then something i think would be
really interesting to do is to kind of
follow in the tracks of this paper right
for the right reasons which um talked
about being able to constrain the
important features for a model when it's
making predictions and i think we have a
unique opportunity to do that here
because if we want a model to think like
us we may have to constrain exactly how
it's making those predictions um using
the indicator variables that we have
and i'm not exactly sure i think i have
a little bit more time but let me know
if i need to leave more time for
questions
um yeah no you're fine you've been going
about um
about 40 to 45 minutes so okay okay time
for questions awesome awesome all right
yeah i'll be done pretty soon here um
and so the last thing i want to do is
kind of open up with the uh i guess pull
back again and talk about the future
directions i see for my work
um
and i think i can ground this in two
papers which have really caught my
attention recently uh the first paper is
from uh you know my own department um
and which one of these authors is my own
pi so full disclosure there um and this
paper discusses the impact of a more
fine-grained ancestry mapping tool uh
that can be better used to understand
healthcare disparities beyond using um
really messy uh group categories like
race ethnicity
and so in the in that paper they
discussed um
they found that there was a huge genetic
difference within racial and ethnic
groups which makes sense i think was
something we've heard before um and
essentially what this boiled down to was
an argument against using race ethnicity
data as a proxy for genetic ancestry
which makes sense when you consider that
there's a lot of historical context
of the in these categories um as i said
before categories are political and they
don't happen in a vacuum
so there's a huge opportunity here
towards uh disentangling uh biological
and clinical indicators from uh
social and cultural uh
aspects of health
um because i i think we will start we
will continue to use race ethnicity
going forward in clinical research um i
think we may start to back away from it
to different degrees
um and instead of using it as a proxy
for genetics uh we also may move away
from using it as a proxy proxy for
social and behavioral determinants as
well
um and i think that's where my work
comes in uh you know there's we'll need
methods to understand not just genetic
context of a patient but also their
social and behavioral determinants of
health context as well
this kind of information can really
allow us to drill down and understand
you know what it is that we mean when we
say
something like native americans have a
higher risk for diabetes
is it only because there's a genetic
risk or are there some socio-cultural
and historical factors that play there
too
and the second paper that's really been
exciting for me is by uh josie at all
and this paper uh really questions
whether or not the belmont report can
really protect american indian and
alaska native people uh when it comes to
research and one of the main points here
is that uh not all of our approach to
ethics that is tribal ethical frameworks
focus on in a focus on the individual
allow them more about the group and
community well-being
and so development report really focuses
on individual autonomy which may be
incongruent for different tribes
and so this paper got me thinking um if
we can question our fundamentals like
the belmont report
can we question how we define and
measure ethics uh when it comes to ai
so specifically looking at something
like indigenous fairness metrics um how
would that how would that work in
clinical ai uh would this include
non-human-centered considerations for
the kin would we have more to do with
how a model is deployed and who in the
community gets to vet that model before
it is used in the community
or maybe it would focus
on how we formulate fairness measures
that focus not just on the outcomes for
the individual
but focus on how this might also affect
the community
and finally bring this all together i
think that it's really exciting that
we're moving away from using race and
ethnicity as a proxy for so many
different factors
but there are still concerns with those
in power including myself
forcing these categories onto different
people which might be incongruent with
their own identities and i think that we
need to be very careful
and include community experts and
scholars with degrees from these
communities in the equation if we're
going to do this right without repeating
the mistakes of the past
um so i'll end there and i want to say
thank you to my lab mates as well as my
committee dr dina uh dr dean of denver
freshman and my p.i you know el haddad
um as well as a training grant funding
them on and if anyone wants to look at
these slides later i have some more
excited here that you're more than
welcome to prove to um
but i'm happy to take questions now and
i'll stop sharing my screen if i can
figure out how to do that
great thanks
um uh very very interesting talk um
and um uh we usually give people the
option of either unmuting and asking
questions or
um typing into the chat i don't see
anything in the chat so i i will ask the
first question um
um how much um i was trying to
as your work was going by um
trying to
determine whether your models your model
may
pick up on other things in the text you
know including
biased or derogatory you know there was
a paper recently about um language and
medical records um and um
you know maybe biased words that are
used um oftentimes in the context of
african-american or native american
patients and so forth um
which which would seem to potentially it
doesn't really bias your model but it
may end up biasing things that you use
your model for like health
determinants and so forth
yeah so um i mean
when we get clinicians to actually
annotate these models uh
it's that's something i'm going to be
looking out for
and like you said it it may not be that
this bias is a model prediction at all
it may perform just as well as any other
any of the other models but
it's going to be very important for you
know if clinicians using this or if
someone finds out those models being
used in their own healthcare records
they might want to know how much can
they trust this model you know is it
picking up on things that they deem
derogatory to their own sense of
identity
um and so
uh you know
i don't think any of the indicators that
we're using would pick up on any
derogatory comments but there were some
actually no there were some race
ethnicity
terms that really aren't used anymore i
think um
i saw a term for asian that isn't just
you know it's not
it's very outdated and not used anymore
so it may be something that the model
learns to pick up on
but yeah yeah i think it'd be something
we have to look into more specifically
rather than just using the indicators
that we have
yeah i i'll let others ask the question
but i mean it may not be derogatory
language this may be um you know kind of
a biased term that gets used in the
context of patients of a certain racial
or ethnic group
absolutely i mean one thing we might see
is like
it may pick up on uh sickle cell disease
a lot when predicting if a patient is
african-american you know which like
there is biases there there's some
genetic information there as well but
you might not want our model to pick up
on that
but yeah that's a good point
yeah oh i see that eric made it welcome
america thank you so much for uh joining
us
here today in
portland virtually uh yeah we can't have
you in person
i'm kind of curious
how your model has worked with in the
context of racial misclassifications
because
what i don't understand and maybe you
went over this and i just
didn't catch it
is like you're relying on other people's
interpretation of someone's race and how
they document it right and so
like even at ohsu like i've encountered
a number of people who the chart calls
african-american
or other patient like other providers
will call the
will identify the person's
african-american and then as soon as i
met them they're just like they're like
hey i'm a citizen of the seminole nation
you know and right i was like
you know everybody gives me all this
stuff about african-american this and
that he's just like yeah but i'm like
i'm a citizen in seminole nation you
know like that's how they identify right
and so like how has your model worked in
that context of like racial
misclassification or racial identity
misclassification
yeah um first of all i think it's a
super important question because
uh
and that's why i want to be so careful
about this work is
the model is
this is different than the model just
making a mistake and not getting the
label that the person assigned to this
the sentence right um this is a much
broader question of
you know we have clinicians who may be
eyeballing a person maybe they ask you
know uh you know what's your rate of
ethnicity how do you identify and maybe
they know that down but you know more
often than not uh maybe not be something
that happens
and so
you know
i haven't looked into exactly how that
would happen because
using the mimic data set we can compare
to the various entity information they
have in the structured data we can also
look at maybe this patient has multiple
notes and certain clinicians identify
them differently and that could be an
indicator that what you're talking about
is happening
but we're also just going to miss a lot
of times when
clinicians just eyeball this patient and
assign rate synthesis without asking
what they you know really identify as
and so
i don't think this model would be
good for handling anything like that um
something i've been approached about is
using this model to uh you know
fill in people's race intensity data
within our own ehr and that was
something i like absolutely bristled
that because
it's just it's not something we should
do like what we should be doing is
asking what is erased and busy how do
you identify and using that um
i think this model might be useful for
uh going back and doing retrospective
analysis
but
i think it's a good point that looking
at
how does this model perform when we know
what the resistance is of this person
because of something they
self-identified as but the
clinicians or the annotations that this
is learning off of
don't reflect that properly my guess is
it's it's not going to pick that up at
all
just a quick comment what i thought you
were gonna do with your presentation
is i thought what was gonna happen is
that you had like native american
african-american
person born in france and like
someone who's spanish speaking and i
thought the end you're going to be just
like yeah and this person
self-identifies as american indian
right right yeah yeah
is an american is this a very recognized
tribe or something like that like that's
what i thought was going to happen
because like i've seen those nuances
anyway
yeah thanks for thanks for joining us
today
yeah absolutely it's good to be really
happy about it
other
questions
comments
had one question um
thank you so much for this talk it was
really interesting um but i was
wondering
um so you said that you froze the bird
model right
i was wondering why you chose to freeze
it instead of fine-tuning it in some way
um and including the like fine-tuning it
with a classifier on top of it
as opposed to
the separate training of the classifier
yeah so
the separate training classifier
yeah so um
the main reason we did that was because
bert has a an immense amount of uh
weights that it has to learn and given
that a data set is way smaller than you
know what the the googles and the
facebooks are going to be using we want
to make sure that we didn't uh too
terribly overtrain our model
because given those that many degrees of
freedom the unfrozen burp would probably
learn uh really specific details in the
training data set um
and you know if we had a larger data set
i would be more comfortable with using
an unfrozen bert and just uh you know
letting it run wild because i think it
would do very well
but i think my main concern was how
small our data set is compared to
how big data sets usually are when
people use bird for them
okay yeah that makes sense um yeah
because in a project also
using sort of like health related data
with this we
used
bert in both a fine-tuning way and in a
non-fine-tuning way and actually did
find that fine tuning was fine but we
had i think like
12 000 um examples so i don't remember
how large your data set was but ah
yeah yeah yeah i mean it's only a
definitely open try yeah i think you
could do well but i think in this one we
had 1600 sentences and i had to split
those up into training and testing right
yeah that's definitely a lot smaller so
yeah
thank you
yeah thank you
so i had a question um i don't know if
we're like raising hands or what but i
had a question um
the uh uh
i apologize if you could mention this
earlier but have you thought about
experimenting with um other kinds of
sentence encoders besides just using
bert
yeah yeah i mean um
it's not something i've looked into as
of yet but
you know um stops me so quickly i
remember when like elmo bert and i think
this yellow and fit were like the big
ones on the block and now we have i
think albert and there's a bunch of
other ones from hugging face um
or implemented by hugging face uh but
yeah so i you know i think
there are some that i could use to
hugging phase
and i know there's a couple other i
can't quite remember the name but they
actually get around the issue of bert
being such a big model and being so data
hungry i could use one of those and i
think it's distilled or something like
that and it might learn
just fine if it was unfrozen too
i think it's a good point there are
definitely others i could try
well and uh specifically for like a
sentence level classification or for
like a hierarchical classification task
like this um something that was trying
to capture the whole sentence might be
we
but
i i think the bird thing was a fabulous
also fabulous way to go and i really
enjoyed the talk i should have said that
first
thank you so much
oh thank you thank you
i'm just taking notes really quickly
because these are really great ideas
thank you everyone
hi this is aaron can i ask a question
hi
i enjoyed your talk as well um i'm just
wondering did you use the the clinical
bert or did which which specific version
of birth did you use there's like a
whole plethora of them now and
it'd be interesting actually to compare
how um you know sort of generic language
versus
you know supposedly clinical language um
would uh
you know identify phrases and pick
things up yeah yeah that's a very good
point um you know clinical bird does
much better on in the clinical setting
uh which absolutely makes sense barrett
was trained on a very general corpus
using a lot of internet stuff
um
for this one we used uh i think bert one
of the smaller versions of the bird just
straight out of the box um you'd
probably get a lot better performance if
you use clinical bear as you mentioned
um
and again like you know i hugging face
the people who make who implement all
this has made it so easy where i can
just
take work download it and then
put it straight into uh their their
architecture so it makes it really easy
but yeah a good point i think there are
a lot of different parts to use and
clinical would probably boost
performance as well
one thing we were worried about that was
if it's going to be a true testing set
if bert's already seen the mimic
clinical notes um
it may not end up mattering but
something we consider
yeah i hear what you're saying i mean
if you're
you know just thinking out loud maybe
just because bert's just trained on the
language and not on a classification
task maybe it doesn't matter you know
that it uh because it's essentially
trained on a different you know language
encoding task and so you know if you're
just using it for the classifier you end
you know whatever the outputs of bertar
into you know putting it into whatever
classification algorithm that that'd be
another thing that i would uh you know i
guess this may be a little
heretical uh stephen can comment on this
but you know everybody wants to use
deep learning for absolutely everything
but i i do think it's worth looking at
some of the you know older algorithms
with the output of the of the embeddings
to to see if they you know do any any
better or different with the
classification and their interpretation
might be
easier i mean
you know i mean
i know this is really her
heretical but if you put it into like a
decision tree and you actually got the
logic that it was using that would be
very very interpretable and not just
some of these weight things where you
have to kind of make a arbitrary
distinction between you know what's uh
what's a high weight and and what's not
kind of thing but in any case i i really
enjoyed what you did and obviously
there's just a million variations that
could be compared
yeah oh no absolutely i mean i think
there's a good spot for uh traditional
machine learning models to do this i
mean the interpretation's a lot clearer
so
definitely worth it worth a shot i think
um i see a question in the chat about
long sentences being great challenge for
accurate analysis
yeah so
my intuition here uh you know i think
what this person's getting at what uh
uh let's see
yeah what's what they're getting at is
um
the longer models had really just weird
wacky uh
interpretations because the weights were
all over the place for the different
features um i think what this gets at is
that the lstm
starts to break down when you get when
you put in longer inputs this is kind of
a known thing with recurrent neural
networks lscms fixes to a degree but not
all the way and so i think what we're
seeing is just
the backwards gradients going through
when we're calculating our important
features getting a little bit mixed up
for that or the model is
getting kind of confused when it get
when it goes through as well
but that's that's my intuition going on
there
oh
um i i don't see
any more questions so um thank you um
for um uh presenting your work to us
it's it's uh very interesting and um
actually maybe in some future time when
you're out uh in these neck of the woods
so we can actually have you
visit in person
and
update us on on your work so um
again i want to thank you for um
speaking at our conference and we'll
look forward to hearing more as your
work progresses great thank you it's a
dribble to be here